let's talk about peace in Yemen and why
some people reckon it's closer than ever
[Applause]
eight years of war have created one of
the world's worst humanitarian disasters
two-thirds of yemenis 22 million people
rely on Aid to survive
there have been several failed attempts
to end the fighting but the U.N managed
to broker a truce a year ago that's
pretty much held up two big players have
been talking to each other and right now
there's this extra momentum one of the
reasons for that is what's going on
between Saudi Arabia and Iran their huge
Regional Rivals who've been on opposite
sides of the conflict in Yemen but
lately they've been patching things up
Saudi Arabia and Iran are restoring
diplomatic relations seven years after
cutting them off and this was a really
big moment when their foreign ministers
met in China to reach that agreement
here's a reminder of how the Saudi Iran
rivalry is played out in Yemen you've
got a saudi-led military Coalition
that's been fighting on the ground and
from the air they support Yemen's
government the internationally
recognized government that was kicked
out back in 2015 by the houthis a rebel
group that Iran has been supporting
mainly by ascending weapons the houthis
are a Shia political military and
religious movement that controls a lot
of territory including the capitals on
op and so these are the two main sides
that have been fighting to control the
country now remember that big moment in
China between Saudi Arabia and Iran well
just three days later we had another
important photo op this one in Yemen
Saudi officials meeting the houthis for
talks in San ah we will see you know a
quite astonishing image of for anyone
who's been following the war in Yemen of
the Saudi Ambassador meeting leading
healthy officials in the same group
posing for photos together
foreign
[Music]
that's not happened that's our Middle
East editor Abu Bakr whose family is
from Yemen he's been helping me
understand what's happening because for
years the UN has tried to broker peace
in Yemen and now you've got the Saudis
and houthis basically doing their own
thing to end the fighting between
themselves with Oman as the mediator is
this real is this the beginning of the
end there are different points of view
on this everyone wants to be hopeful
um and you've got some people saying
that this potentially could finally be
the deal that ends the war right then of
course you've got another angle or
another side who are still hopeful but
they're also raising a lot of questions
and a lot of doubts now we don't have
too many details about the potential
deal but we know they're talking about
things like a permanent ceasefire the
withdrawal of foreign forces from Yemen
meaning Saudi forces and fully reopening
ports controlled by the houthis which
should make it much much easier for
yemenis to receive Food and other
Essentials this is where the Hope comes
from the
just
um easing the restrictions that yemenis
have faced and of course these
restrictions haven't just come from one
side but you know a lot of them have
come from Saudi Arabia and decisions
that were made
in an effort to support the Emily
government another hopeful sign was this
recent prisoner exchange of almost 900
people
[Music]
um
foreign
so it really feels like things are
moving in a positive direction and for
Saudi Arabia it seems that now they just
want out it's been a long and expensive
War that's also reached into their
country
the houthis have fired thousands of
rockets and missiles over the Border
the Saudis have shot down a lot of them
but some attacks have done damage like
this one that hit an important oil
facility the Saudis this is a conflict
that's been going on for so many years
they thought would be over so quickly
and they have not been able to defeat
the houthis Muhammad bin Salman in
particularly the Crown Prince he wants
to develop saudi's economy and their
thinking is that these security issues
that this conflict is bringing up is
going to scare away investors their
thinking is just let's cut our losses
um whilst maintaining will ensuring that
our security
remains basically the thing about these
talks is that they're just between the
Saudis and the houthis but there are a
lot of other groups fighting in Yemen
for example there's the southern
transitional Council which controls a
large area in the South they want to
break away and create their own State
and remember there's also Yemen's
government the one that Saudi Arabia has
been fighting to reinstate it's not
clear if their people are actually
getting much of a say in what's been
going on she got various other forces
that have their own beef with the
healthy so to speak they will feel that
they need to be included and they can't
just be overlooked and it will be the
intricacies and the details of that deal
and then we'll really be able to
understand whether this is the real deal
or whether unfortunately it's just going
to set up things for a second stage of
this walk that will continue just in a
different form some yemenis also think
the deal could amount to Saudi forces
pulling out and essentially handing the
country over to the houthis that's
something that many people are worried
about for a lot of young
the idea of how these ruling over them
is akin to let's say the Taliban ruling
over Afghanistan for many afghans
it's just something that they do not
want so even with all the signs of
progress towards a deal between the
Saudis and houthis there's still a lot
of skepticism because it'll take so much
more to achieve a lasting peace for the
whole of Yemen
there are really important elections
happening in Turkey there's a chance
that President erdogan could get voted
out after 20 years in power check out
our explainer to get up to speed
[Music]